he was very aggressive early in the
count last night and finished the game
with three more hits
and that's well hit into the right
corner and that is inside the foul pole
for a pesky paul home run at fenway park
you could just tell by the way he took
off and where he hit it that it was
gonna it was gonna slice that pole right
there
oh nice start for win
arlo santana had a big hit in the first
inning last night
and that's a line drive to right field
and that will bounce inside the pesky
pole for a double
santana hit a three run home run in the
first last night
and the royals for a second straight
night come out swinging the bat well at
fenway park
swinging a fly ball into the left field
verdugo back he's back and he'll make
the play on the warning track and that
will retire the side kansas city strikes
first one to nothing royals after a half
inning two on for jd martinez will climb
into 297 2-1 to martinez
hit into left-center red sox quickly on
the board [ __ ] will score
verdugo wants third the throw is cut
down to second there's the throw and got
him
jd trying to pick up a bag there after
the run scoring single and sox have tied
it 1-1
now gets the curveball again as you can
see right here and takes it right back
up the middle for the baits hit keller
home with a no two
got him lunging little trickler running
trying to score here's the scoop by
revere he'll go to first and won't get
him another run in red sox have grabbed
the lead and xander hauls it on down to
second it is 2-1 boston
rivera with a misfire
yeah that's going to go as a base
hitting an error i'm sure because just a
little tap down the third base line you
can see
that vadugo has no problem scoring then
the throw goes eric to first base which
allows bogarts to get in scoring
position at second good throw would not
have him at first base
and another ground ball this one's right
to wit
and that will be an ending ending double
play but the royals get one the red sox
get two
dozier hits it well into left center
field and that will hit the monster
bare-handed by vardugo
and his throw comes in high
and hunter dozier has a lead-off double
yeah he barreled that one
that's fastball right down the middle
good swing plenty of room there see how
he's getting it out of the batter's box
that's what's going to get you that
double here you bare hands it they can
get it in and throw you out in a
heartbeat there if it's a good throw it
would have been close
back to the middle and into center field
so he'll advance the runner two bases
dozier scores from second and the royals
tied at two they're feasting on the
fastball anything in the middle
and that's lined into left center field
dalbeck will make the turn and go to
third and he will be out
and for the royals that's their second
out on the bases
in two innings that's three consecutive
walks by keller to load the bases for
hunter renfro
swinging a shot
that one out to center taylor covers the
ground makes the catch
tagging up here comes jd is in the score
and the red sox are back in front here
they lead it three to two the rbi for a
hunter renfro number 41. well of course
as a hitter you always want more but
that's good hitting right there that's
situational hitting get the ball in the
air get the man at third base let him
tag let him come home
grounded to the right side and santana
is there so it could have been a lot
worse the red sox get three walks but
score only one and lead 3-2
[Applause]
under dozier lines one to the gap
and he's going to have his second
straight extra base hit two for two with
two doubles and back come the royals
down by one they have a runner at second
base with nobody out
and he hits one to the right side and
that drives renfro back and that is in
the bullpen
for an opposite field two run home run
so taylor twice tonight trying to do the
team thing by advancing the runner in
front of him 90 feet has done much
better than that and the royals lead 4-3
the cookie in the middle and he's
waiting for it that's what you want to
do be ready right away when a runner in
scoring position
look at this isn't that a beautiful
thing yeah and santana down to third
dolby hitting behind the runner first
and third nobody out
hit that ball stiff down for a base hit
in to score santana
red sox quickly tie the ball game four a
piece on the single second one of the
ball game by [ __ ] he's been hot since
being back in that lead off spot started
to get hot before the transition back to
the lead-off spot and stayed hot
all loaded up and the 1-2 coming
swinging a fly ball in the center field
taylor there backing up
and tagging up biz dolbeck he will trot
in
and the red sox are back in front
rbi number 49 for genie martinez
hit well to center field santana goes
back turns and it's gone
ryan o'hearn with a laser beam home run
to straight away center field
and the royals have regained the lead
wow
what a swing
bottle that up
boy that is perfect just what you want
hit the ball right back where it's
coming from that'll put runners at first
and second with one gone and send up jd
swings and rips that one down the line
that will settle on the warning track
one run is in
gradual rounding here's the play
he slides in safely
jd martinez down the line and the socks
are back in front seven to six oh
beautiful opposite feel hitting there by
jd martinez didn't wait around first
pitch that he saw
trying to strike out the side here in
the ninth inning
he got him to go he struck him out
vasquez tosses on
matt barnes is a nasty boy he strikes
out the side
and the red sox win it their fifth
consecutive w seven to six